Mariah Carey reunites with her ex Nick  Cannon to celebrate Halloween with their  five-year-old twins good for the kids  the friendly exes got in the holiday  spirit throwing an over-the-top party  Saturday night with the whole family  involved try my hardest I always become  happy that was Mariah last Halloween as  a glamorous witch this year the pop diva  opted for a dangerously devilish look  Mimi sported another sexy figure fitting  costume looking red-hot in a latex devil  costume with wings only her special  occasion daughter Monroe opted for the  Rapunzel costume from tangled while Nick  was totally twinning with his son  Moroccan dressing up as Super Mario  Brothers Mario and Luigi and here's the  cutest shot of the duo adorably spinning  at the DJ booth  you